happy birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey turn up girls it's your sweet 16.
[Music]
now if anyone knows how to throw a party
it's ditty I want to get it right and he
showed out for his twin daughters Jesse
and Delilah's sweet 16 birthday bash
even gifting them both with Range Rovers
it's just it's a sense of Pride um that
you know I was able to go and make I was
able to make that dream come true the
twins futuristic themed birthday
celebration went down on Sunday
[Applause]
the teenagers whom Diddy shares with his
Latex model Kim Porter were matching
ensembles the first look a metallic
jumpsuit with futuristic Shades and
rapper coilerae who performed at the
party took a moment to show off their
second look a two-piece bodysuit okay
first of all the twin sweet 16 we are
going crazy they're switching into Alpha
number two and I'm backstage and I get
to see you speak
oh my God you guys are not ready
oh my God sneak peek they're gonna go
crazy what
happy birthday what thank you the lavish
party included people tearing up the
Dance Floor
and another performance from the twins
brothers King and Quincy
[Music]
but the moment that stole the night the
twins reaction to a surprise gift from
their daddy it was you know it was just
beautiful
Diddy's daughters were ecstatic when
they walked outside to see two Range
Rovers one white and black and another
all black
[Applause]
being able to see my kids and and give
them that comfort of them seeing me and
everything's all right it's a beautiful
thing
[Applause]
it's clear Diddy is all about supporting
his kids
[Applause]
in March he took his other 16 year old
daughter chance as his date to the
Oscars first of all the biggest thing
that's going on tonight is me bringing
my daughter to this because she's an
aspiring actress and we get to have a
date and I I'm just so excited and I'm
just so stunned I'm at a loss of words
so
um I'm blessed to be here you know we
got I'm presenting tonight and we're
gonna have a good time but I'm like I
wish you were dealing with Daddy
emotionally when she walked out yeah
right right what did you say what did
you say what the [ __ ] is going on
I love it there's gonna have to be some
hard conversations coming up no no they
they know what's up
[Music]